maryline de mes musiciens live avec nous
dans une autre couleur naturelle profil
mais c'est plus dur ces bruits ne sait
plus dur quand j'ai vu le jour dans une
émission c'est daniela lumbroso sur un
sur lci
et alors un moment elle était
interloquée parce que vous avez dit et
je crois que c'est un peu le coeur du
film
vous avez dit être tolérant cm1 raciste
pas parce qu'il est raciste et parce que
c'est un être humain et elle n'a pas
compris l'annoncé la pub et je crois que
non mais non mais je veux dire c'est
vrai la compassion c'est ça quand le
pape va pardonner ali agça qui lui a
tiré des balles dans le ventre c'est
pareil bon c'est vrai que moi je cherche
toujours à comprendre puisque condamné
je sais pas pour être souvent la
tolérance et d à sens unique
c'est vrai que c'est mieux si marilyn
par exemple dans le film un moment bon à
la sa carte du front national c'est
parce qu'elle ait pas d'autres solutions
pour trouver du boulot je dirais c'est
pas parce que les nazis c'est parce
qu'elle est raciste et c'est ce que je
trouve bien dans ce film tout à fait
même le pur et dur moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est savoir je vais devoir
m'asseoir lui dire comment il en est
arrivé là et comment il en est arrivé là
pardon paris dans des sketches peut
passer des heures à se poser une
question à la fin il répond à cette
question et l achat sont célèbres ou pas
ben oui c'est qu'on a une conviction de
ses terres et je crois que tata ça ça
ouais ou pas c'est d'être capable
d'envisager le point de vue de l'autre
ou pas c'est à dire qu'un taille à bulle
c'était plus compliqué qu'on disait il y
avait quelqu'un qui habite rayonner tous
le compte quelque 1 1 on est tous
l'étranger de quelqu'un
enfin bon bref on sait bien que ça
marche vous dit chez nous bâle est bien
quand j'étais petit palais bien c'était
inconcevable seul remède contre le
cafard c'était de faire le tour du pâté
de maisons c'était marche ou crève
et là vers l'âge de 5 6 ans vous
découvrez que finalement le rire peut
sauver les pires moments
et quand vous êtes à l'arrière de la
voiture je régime que chez vous on a des
détroits donc on imagine bien les deux
maps est à côté de moi et moi au milieu
moi je suis allé faire des tours en
voiture j'imagine ça on allait dans
l'amont brison la ola le village un peu
plus petit que cette hausse hier la
journée voir les amis des jeunes est
alors là vous découvrez en fait que dans
la voiture ou dit des vannes ça fait
marrer tout le monde donc et vous dites
je me sentais responsable de leur
bonheur à tous oui c'est exactement ça
responsable j'avais cette responsabilité
là il alors à l'époque un peu comme dans
marilyn lamari vif
évidemment les coûts de joe dassin en se
mettant sa veste blanche et sa chemise
blanche vous vous enfermez dans votre
champ avec al jarreau barry white et
stevie wonder
c'est vrai que je crois que je me suis
chouchoutée as a way parce que de 12 ans
à 17 ans comment le déjeuner était dure
à peu près un quart d'heure ce n'est pas
pas de plaisir donc on mange pour manger
quoi non c'est à dire dix minutes à tout
casser un gardien et après dont jusqu'à
jusqu'à la sonnerie d'école que
j'entendais chez moi c'est vrai je vais
peut-être
et voilà tout ça j'étais arrivé en
classe sous les c'est une drogue avec le
sentait rêver ça pour ce pauvre tenir le
coup il y avait ça y est le rire
évidemment
et y'a pas à dire que d'un seul coup
comme beaucoup d'entre nous vous dites
je vais monter à paris parce que là où
toute façon tout est possible donc vous
arrivez ici est la première chose que
vous faites en arrivant on en voit bien
là la fille de marchand de chaussures
qu'elle avait marre de porter les pompes
qu'on lui faisait met vous acheter des
bottes je me suis acheter des bottes
magnifique c'est marrant je sais
exactement les votes pour fait
maintenant le fait grise très pointu
c'est un truc de tester les talons comme
ça c'était plus basse et plus branché à
saint-etienne avait pas des modèles
comme ça des talons de 10 centimètres
pour le tue donc j'étais très embêté
d'aller pour la première fois dans un et
je me souviens j'ai laissé un pourboire
la fille parce que vend des chaussures
c'est pas vendre les c'est difficile les
choses qui vont acheter des chaussures
ils sont insupportables les gens soient
fait mal aux pieds zem pas la couleur
elles sont trop longs rails
machin on y va pour se baisser et ses 15
cartons sa tombe
sinon quelqu'un qui me gêne c'est
l'impression de tromper mes parents
alors à paris vous arrivez de cours
florent pour préparer le conservatoire
elle est reçue première à l'entrée du
conservatoire et la faisait michel
bouquet comme prof c'est pas mal hein
c'est mieux que ça faisait de la chance
et là vous travaillez l'aiglon agrippine
ce qui fait que finalement quand on
quand on vous voit dans marilyn les gens
ont l'impression que c'est comme ça le
truc qui vous a pris un jour
j'arrête de faire de la scène je vais
faire du cinéma vous avez commencé comme
ça alors est ce que finalement le
comique ça a été une parenthèse mais
c'est incroyable cette histoire vous
êtes parti là non on va voir comment
j'ai jamais pensé moi j'aurais dit tiens
je vais partir de cet été pour faire ça
c'est pas c'est pas et je me suis
retrouvé quand il va faire ça on
m'aurait dit ça va durer 12 ans j'aurais
dit mais comment
mais alors qu'est ce que je devais faire
donc je vais rater plein de trucs donc
j'étais dans la danse dans le voyage et
comme voilà dans ces familles aussi je
commence quand on finisse pas annoncer
cela commence et tout ça mais c'est pas
des paroles c'est vrai bien ce qu'ils
ont créé impossible de faire autrement
et alors là il ya un truc que difficile
à comprendre pourquoi c'est un coup de
blues à la fin du conservatoire pourquoi
vous rentrez pas dans une troupe de
théâtre
vous partez à saint-etienne revendre des
chaussures ça s'est un peu voilà déduire
le jour vous êtes reparti non c'est de
rester et l'amener en amérique centrale
mais comment tout seul non je m'arrête à
un ami que je débauche avec un sac à dos
et voilà et on part pour deux mois et je
me dis ben voilà et quand je reviens je
vais la vie c'est ça ouais donc tu vas
travailler un peu faire tout un show et
tous les ans qui partira deux mois c'est
à dire deux mois on le regarde plus la
date on y vend rentrer dans une semaine
oui le temps est complètement c'est en
80 je n'y ai plus jamais passer ça
c'est vrai que chaque fois certains
combats sous les panneaux j'ai perdu
c'est ça ouais on dit toujours que la
vie c'est ça qu'on va c'est pas mieux il
faut pas exactement au point et là on
retourve reprenez à tout à zéro avec
roger louret les baladins de l'agenais
bouvard le petit théâtre mais rencontre
énorme avec pierre palmade évidemment on
a vu ce que ça a donné
bedos et puis là voilà vous fait une
carrière que complètement rien à voir
avec ce qui aurait dû être la vôtre
parce qu'au départ première vocation
c'est la musique et après vous auriez dû
faire du théâtre là vous faites du one
man show incroyable
seul sur scène mais vous dites au fond
je me sens comedians et cette phrase qui
très gentil je me sens plus proches de
suzanne flon que patrick bosso je fais
sont plus proches de suzanne flon et
peut-être bayador vous voulez faire des
vacances à l'euro manoeuvre qui a
beaucoup cité
paris may be nice